welcome to this video playing be pods
and from the yes it's probably Brian
Paul's in the authored at least one book
let's see what we get here queens in
yeah i went for Knight f3 for a change
not going for the for the names oh and
it seems him knows this stuff this is a
I think it's SIA freedom checking I
thought I or national master from the US
I'm not I'm not shown so you have it in
them no pretty pretty new account as
well he's a good player in those books
are okay he made one book about
something about the semi sloth but so
what was good okay let's see probably
want to play c5 at some point Queen a 4c
50 maybe I'm not not very knowledgeable
about those positions I just wanted you
to do something else besides the same
ish all the time but isn't this quite ok
I have 95 also here maybe night is not
bad though
knight c6 is a self pen so probably not
very advisable mmm not sure if I want to
take probably better that I retreated
hmm
not clear to me this position now I
don't really have any big experience iam
black seems very a very reasonable to me
here do i do I get get ahead him and not
that a good pawn structure simply but
not it's also not clear what he should
do
Roxy want the ideas maybe if I get it in
to play see for take on the 65 again ask
the Queen trade you know this is an
interesting interesting question should
i do this or should I don't should I
don't or shouldn't I
so if I avoid it we also go to c6 so
probably probably I should take it
yeah I'm slightly worse but i don't i
don't think it should be a it should be
terrible okay yeah I know I'm pretty
confident that I'm okay rook takes my
cam though it's really nothing terrible
going on
ok
yeah need to get used to the fact that i
have this comparatively a low rating
from my from my standards and people
just want to win even if they have no
particular have no particular reason to
do so from the position he's odd rating
me 100 something points so probably just
wants to try to win no matter how is bit
more active
and one minute on the clock grawr our
third okay run around not showing black
black seems better here look a fruit a
for king of six lost kind of stuff but
let's uh let's start from the beginning
I really don't don't know the opening
here too well chan he definitely a new
it better playing very quickly yeah I
already don't know if this is so this is
any good that's an interesting spot i
don't i don't really think i can avoid
the Queen's radium if I move the Queen
somewhere you off we get the Queen to be
six matter to see six maybe my mean
something like this there's for example
I mean this is probably helping him and
here I mean I should be okay I have
enough enough activity two to trade this
off yeah maybe night takes us even a bit
better for white hmm the Arab cakes was
a bad decision actually I was feeling a
bit on the defensive from the earlier
part of the game and this is not a good
trade activating his night it's much
better to take he and ask him okay
where's your not going yeah this is
slightly better for why this position
because of his bed bed a 59 can't hear
that's really not much going on but I
was feeling slide slide time is she
coming so probably didn't play this too
well yeah g4 he's got King f 6m it's got
the King f6 my desire to exchange
pawns could have cost me and q6 don't
really have a good move here can just
grab him I g4 was very bad no okay yeah
but not great what I did here but draw
at the end okay thanks for watching